so damn you got like fluent and kanji i
guess similar to joey can't write for
[ __ ] though you can't write but you can
read can't you right yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's the usual i mean when i talk to jan
it's like i'm talking to a native yeah
yeah like it's it's like i can tell not
only you are actually fluent but you
also like because you know there are
people who just know the vocab but don't
actually understand the culture behind
the language yeah when i speak to jan
it's like he clearly also gets the
culture i think that's because we both
follow anime manga you know
into yeah but i mean it also helps again
that your dad you know did that whole
choo choo choo choo choo lee's japanese
technique which i honestly would
recommend to any parent yeah no yeah i
mean it's there's two examples that has
been proven to work right it's a must
man
honestly i think so when did you move to
japan originally to like come live here
um so i would visit every year to see my
grandparents and hang out here and i
think that's one of the reasons also why
you know that there's no other cultural
gap
my vocabulary for example yeah yeah but
i moved here permanently about three
years ago so right after you know
graduating from jochi
um you know to actually start working
here mm-hmm
and became my house
no so that's that
that's never been my like main
professional right yeah so it's like a
side hustle uh yeah basically how long
did you get full time um
of course i started after 18.
yeah of course
before that but um so
so it's been how long seven years since
i started i guess uh because i'm 25 now
is that is that a long time for a host
like what's like the average that a host
would be a host fully dude it really
depends on the club but i would say like
the general life span of a single house
is pretty short yeah it seems like all
right
yeah honestly really hard but the thing
is like in my case for example you know
i would i wasn't like a full-time right
yeah like for example until i moved here
permanently it was always like a summer
one month thing
so for like the audience or like the
customers it was like oh my god i can
only see this dude one month out of the
whole year that that's crazy because for
me it's like i
during my breaks i would just like go
and play xbox like the whole time i
didn't even have the capacity to even
find jan was on that grind
how did you even like so so you became a
host you said like what for one month
for summer
from like how did that yeah
like get into like
i'm so curious okay so to go over um
since you know even before i was 18 i
would always go to kabukicho
you know like the the host century yeah
yeah the red light district exactly the
closest thing to that that's where all
the amalgamation of the
fun cool [ __ ] and together happens and
sketchy stuff yeah
also very scary yeah but you know like i
would hear stories from my dad how this
street was because my dad used to work
there too at a bar called saboten my dad
is like a huge ass [ __ ] he was
like a bouncer for one of the you know
bars back in the day right so you would
tell me how i used to play a card with
like you know
people who are missing a portion of
their finger right right right there so
i was really curious to see like what is
this place like now so i would go there
with my um
to look around you know
so i would go there and like the people
there just you know treated me like i'm
an adult you know right like i mean it
don't be like that when you're like half
turkish yeah exactly you have a [ __ ]
weird like this yeah you're 40 years old
yeah exactly exactly i never had an
issue like buying or doing anything here
you know yeah yeah so
yeah at that time i would go there just
to experience what it's like you know
see places it's not like i did anything
or just you know looking yeah um and
then you know
um once i turned 18 i decided well when
i'm going to japan i should probably
make some money meaning i should do some
vital yeah because my dad was like well
now that you're 18 i ain't gonna give
you any money bro just do something yeah
you know so i was like all right am i
going to work at a you know [ __ ]
pizzaia yeah or hosto
and then i decided to choose the
why was that your two options surely
there's more choices so when i was 18
my father i will work for dominoes
or the sketchiest bar in tokyo
which one should i choose extremes yeah
will you put it like that it's like it's
not my first two choices
okay okay so to go over why that just
went to mcdonald's
the way it transpired is that um when i
turned 18 near my parents house there
was a pieza called
i'm not going to name it because it's my
surname what is it
uh
so the shop's name was literally my
surname so i went there chat with the
guy he's like yo we have the same
surname and he looks like exactly like
me bro this guy japanese has a beard
huge nose and everything was he talking
about no he's not he's not but when we
came really good friends and he was like
why don't you work here you know i heard
you're here for the summer you know i'll
give you good cash 900 in an hour yeah
ballin
like it's like 10 bucks yeah but it was
like you know free food all day bro i'm
like [ __ ] let's go so i started working
there for you know
a few months yeah
um when i was 18 i stayed in japan for
much longer than one month actually uh
probably like four months the first two
months i was there on my work there and
then i started taking night shifts
because my you know teen troll wanted me
to make drinks and serve it to the
customers at the counter oh and he said
it was like a pizza place that served
alcohol exactly right right and then the
main customers that come in the evening
were
milfs let's say
i'm happy with that
so
he was like yo john
so he's like a ex-sports teacher you
know he still has good ties with the
school and all of his like you know like
ex-students i'm he's still in contact
with i now are all adults yeah and most
of the females are like married they
have kids they're like 25 and you know
when you're 25 and you're married to a
30 year old japanese guy and he's away a
lot and you know maybe he has like an
erectile dysfunction
you kind of want to she kind of wants to
go talk to other people right okay
we [ __ ] at the pizzeria
what you're describing literally sounds
like the start of a porn
that's gonna happen a lot throughout
this episode
i mean one thing that we should probably
mention is that uh cheating culture in
japan is pretty prevalent right it's
[ __ ] it's it's very normal yeah
yeah nuts bro yeah that's crazy yeah so
i started working at this pizza place um
taking a nice show shows making drinks
for these ladies
chatting with them and i realized
they're coming back especially to chat
with me that's what the boss is telling
me they're like yo
you know
these ladies they want to hang out with
you after dangerously feeding an 18 year
old yeah yeah yeah and then i realized
that they're allowed to buy drinks for
me while you know i'm making drinks for
them so i'm like the [ __ ] out of pizza
places
yo guys it is what's happening
where did we get the drinks from i
thought
i thought i had the image of like the
domino's counter yeah you were just
taking it i don't think this is a pizza
place i think this is a bar that serves
pizza well it's like a really high-end
pizza place that has a really really
sexy counter with like you know a lot of
high-end alcohol kind of lined up right
okay and then there's a nice you know
stool that people can sit on and then
drink on one one with the barking right
right soul ball
well with pizza attached to yeah yeah so
it's a bar that serves pizza it's not a
pizza place
you don't have to fear the pizza boys
so um after after like a month or so
working there you know in the night
shift i realized that you know
i may be good at this right
my boss was like and he's such a nice
guy bro you know
of course of course because i go hang
out with him still already sales and
[ __ ] so he told me you know
you told um because i was telling him
talking to about being becoming a hostel
like initially but i told him you know
like i don't want my parents down okay
so why did you want to be a host
initially before you entered easy money
man easy money bro guys like think about
it there's a job where you literally get
paid money to drink with girls yeah and
just chat with them when i did my video
the money i saw that they were getting
paid was insane yeah yeah yeah it was it
was like some of them could make like
fifty thousand dollars a night yeah easy
if you if it's just why are we youtubers
they [ __ ] left at me when they were
like how much do you make and i told
them how much i made like the year
before
and they were like that's how much you
made they all started [ __ ] laughing
i was like what the [ __ ] like look at
this peasants
some of them don't pay tax you know yeah
exactly just right off whatever the [ __ ]
it's crazy bro so okay so what was the
process of like getting into your first
hosting job then okay so after the piece
of stuff i decided to apply right yeah
um you can apply like like you do you
just talk to someone or do you have like
a job offer yeah so you go on the
[ __ ] internet guys holy [ __ ]
so you just type in you know
you just craigslist right so you just
find the nearest one so i went to the
one in ikebukuro because that was like
five minutes train away from where i was
living at that time
i'm not sure if that was attention that
was a tension
he's drinking a gin and tonic by the way
oh yeah it's like two in the afternoon
we we want to drink but we can't we have
our health checks yeah we have a health
check let me go over like real quick i
have to get on with myself okay okay so
people listen to me okay we've been
discussing about you know this podcast
day for like a year you know since we
met we're trying to get channel for a
while now yeah and then i was always
like you know we're gonna get [ __ ]
smashed when i show up right are you
guys [ __ ] ready and last week um i
had to cancel because some [ __ ] happened
and then you know i said about next week
yeah let's do it yeah and i show up
today with this bottle
and the first thing they say they're
like ah
we can't drink today though
damn i'm sorry to be fair john we have
been asking you for a whole year yeah 52
weeks which is not this week yeah to say
yes
so so that's that's a valid enough
excuse to not let me know that you can't
drink this week we we didn't think about
it but we didn't think about it we
actually i actually completely forgot i
had a health checkup until this morning
i came out yeah yeah yeah i was like oh
yeah that's tomorrow [ __ ]
i i have nurses i mean it's okay we'll
drink when uh the cameras are off uh
when it's not today yeah it's just like
we're like we always do yeah like we all
like like exactly
the day that this episode goes up we'll
drink helpful [ __ ] yeah yeah there we go
so save it on twitter
i'll compare you with something yeah
yeah no it doesn't work that way bro you
know because something i want to go
around camping everyone individually i'm
like
he's a cheers though yeah